like a Heat of the Moment type of reflex
it's not hip-hop beefs remember hip-hop
beefs the documentary God damn I'm glad
you all said it all
[Music]
kirschnick Corey ball AKA take off
American red that's his name Amigos yeah
has been shot and killed at the age of
28 at an event in Houston Texas so young
yeah it sucks 28. I thought he was way
older did you yeah it's mature uh in uh
in the same group he has an uncle I
think cuevo is his uncle
um I'm not actually familiar with their
family lineage that much but yeah it's
quavo offset and taking and take off one
of them's an uncle one was like a cousin
or something like that or a nephew so
they're all related technically if one's
Uncle for sure I didn't know they were
family like that I thought they were
like gangster that was like I'm family
yeah cuevo's Uncle AKA cuevius cayate
Marshall and the cousin is offset Chiari
Kendra cephas and their real names are
hella tires yeah they're way cooler they
remind me of that one key and peels
Demetrius Johnson
Walker
devontavious yeah Aquarius Aquarius
madarious Aquarius
the third depends the blind man Johnson
over some dumb [ __ ] too what's the scoop
what's the scoop Ryan always knows the
scoop right no I don't know I just know
I just know it came out I don't know
they don't know if it's like this is
exactly what happened but they were
outside of a venue and then there was
like a dice game going on and then
somebody said some [ __ ] like somebody
said something to cuevo talking about
like well I could kick your ass and then
um from there it just escalated
it just escalated and then she
apparently takeoff got shot just by a
stray bullet from that altercation oh my
God even he wasn't even talking or doing
anything he was just like off to the
side and then he just got hit yeah
oh that's like way more heartbreaking
apparently he got hit he wasn't really
involved in the altercation and they do
have pictures of the dude like uh from
different people's sources like their
social media you can see him like
pulling the gun out and [ __ ] oh there's
so many videos of it it sucks yeah this
is so [ __ ] sad because I thought we
um like kind of outgrew that generation
because it we did but they didn't oh
because they're still the same age we
got older oh I see because like what do
you mean outgrew that so in our
generation like uh Tupac and Biggie when
Tupac and Biggie got shot that was uh I
mean it's not good but it was more of
like a normal thing even like uh Young
Buck stab someone
um I got an award right like just like
that kind of like violence well we still
gotta remember publicly dude I feel like
way more rappers are getting killed
these days but it's not we still have no
no no no they're still
um [ __ ] who's a dude who got his
chain Rob low voice in the [ __ ] hold
on there's Nipsey hostage pnb Rock he
got killed recently yeah there's still
nipsy hustle that happened that was a
big one right yeah dude that's like on
par with like yeah nipsy hustle was huge
and then um shot in front of the place
he invested to develop too right yeah
and he was a huge Community person that
was it wasn't just like rap beef that
was online he was like really preaching
and trying to change and was that also
over some like like pretty stupid [ __ ]
too I think it was the same with pop
smoke yeah smoke was murdered as well I
think the the question is whether or not
these are like you know Gang Related
violences where it's like
um intentionally trying to like go at
somebody versus like an altercation that
escalated from some like a Heat of the
Moment type of a reflex it's not hip-hop
beefs
remember hip-hop beefs the documentary
it's like a compilation of all the drama
and Hip-Hop
Hip-Hop beefs that's why he's eating his
chips it's not hip-hop beef
I just love when Joe just asks questions
like that my favorite video of JK ever
to this day is when Joe went was talking
to Julia and he goes did you ask I would
have asked
that's my favorite [ __ ] clip of all
there's so much comedic value and
someone's just going y'all remember
hip-hop beefs
because he says that like everyone knows
but no one knows
he's got this smile on his face just so
smug you don't know hip-hop beef huh
oh my God but yeah you are right that is
I feel like that is I think it's still
happening in in rap today as much as it
did before we just don't follow it as
closely because back in the day you just
you you just couldn't escape news like
that in school because everyone was
talking about it yeah yeah but nowadays
just the people in our circles don't
talk about that I feel like on the
internet every like quarter a big rapper
passes away so a lot of rappers are
killing themselves too like let's not
forget about that there's a lot of
people with drug issues and you know
depression and [ __ ] so yeah but to to
his point though that's like a different
conversation of like ending themselves
right we're talking about just like the
uh the rapper Game that uh somebody gets
shot and killed someone tries to rob
them someone does it just sucks that
it's over like dumb [ __ ] like this like
that what a [ __ ] waste like you had
this this dude Amigos and everything
that they could have accomplished
together for so long and cut short by
some like dumb [ __ ] he was a big part of
music too
um you know a lot of people looked up to
him he was super super talented and for
him to not even be involved is so sad I
know we lost Coolio this year let's not
forget about that but he kind of like
did his thing that was through what like
uh was it through illness yeah is there
more it's like a heart issue more like
regular methods like knowing that
someone could reach Legend status like
that like you know like Migos and and
takeoff they would have hit Legend
status for sure yeah but then you know
did he have heart attack in a bathroom
Coolio yeah I don't know I don't know
about it in the bathroom I don't know
the location not another specifically
they didn't put that in the TFC report
not he had a heart attack in a bathroom
like and it was taking a long time and
then his friend was knocking on a door
and you wouldn't answer so and then this
was like in Vegas or something did you
have a heart attack while standing on
tiles
he's got a heated seat I don't know
one of those Japanese toilets talks to
you they heard the bidet go on way too
long he was he was discovered
unresponsive on a bathroom floor and it
was cardiac arrested you know your [ __ ]
dude hip-hop beef dude I know my [ __ ] I
just express it funny
I know my [ __ ] I just express it funny
rap autopsies.com
[Laughter]
or it's like rap clue it's like on the
toilet 5 p.m
in the living room yeah and just a shout
shout them out because they went through
some [ __ ] that night too two other
people a 23 year old man and a 24 year
old woman were also injured in the
shooting and took themselves to the
hospital with non-life-threatening
injuries
um but yeah a bus that that take off who
was not part of the altercation was the
one who was shot in the crossfire and
killed on site dude that's the thing man
just bad bad timing I feel like violence
is probably not as crazy as when like
when we were younger
um as in like how frequent like the
fight fist fights and physical like it
was fights breaking out all the time but
I do think it does like
young men or young men like they're
gonna have that aggression like meaning
um we get older and like chill out but
they still want to fight yeah I noticed
that because I was talking to a younger
dude from sgv and I was like telling him
how it used to be growing up and I'm
like you guys are lucky you don't got to
deal with the [ __ ] that we just like I
felt like everywhere I went back then in
like the late 90s early 2000s I just
could get my ass kicked for no reason
you could be eating yeah a pork chop at
a cafe and a gangster just like yeah
they're like looking at you they're like
why are you staring at me and I'm like
I'm just eating my [ __ ] pork chop
dude what the [ __ ] and then they stab
you with a fork and it's like what the
[ __ ] yeah dude but then but then it was
interesting because he said so this dude
was like 18 and he was like nah dude
it's still really bad it's just like
that now and I realize it's just where
you go it's like whatever your circle is
and if that's the kind of thing like if
you're looking for [ __ ] action you're
going to takeovers and [ __ ] like yeah of
course you're gonna think the whole
world is violent you feel the whole yeah
I feel like dice games are always a hot
spot you know if you go to a dice if
you're gonna get [ __ ]
Ed they'll go in the bathrooms and play
dice and um one time I was taking a [ __ ]
and I was like scared for my life
because they were playing ice in the
bathroom
oh dude they were like shooting in there
and I was like or it hits her shoe and
it becomes a number they didn't want but
I was like his shoes
yeah yeah
kick him like oh who's taking this [ __ ]
and I was like oh no
I'm so scared no one no not me you know
yeah it really is the places you
frequent yeah you know and in places
change too like this neighborhood
um it's way different than the
neighborhood we grew up in like it's the
same neighborhood but the even the
people's different so the community
change there's more money the school
system's good like if you look at the
school systems in like Monterey Park now
they got like super high ratings where
like when we were going to school there
it was like they were running PSAs on on
trying to get funding and then they
would have like all this footage of how
[ __ ] up the school was we need funding
whatever and I think all that money that
they poured in during our generation
they fixed it up and then like now all
that money that was spent then is being
used and like you can see like the
efforts so then all the test scores and
everything they're crushing it but then
like in our generation it's like kids
were smoking behind the bushes and
getting caught for like ecstasy and
stuff and yeah I feel yeah I mean it's
everywhere I just had two homies the
other day
um leaving Comedy Club on Sunset they
got robbed at gunpoint like my friend's
face got smashed in they were good
um but there's just friends face got
smashed yeah they're good they're good
but I mean he was in the hospital and
stuff but like these were just like two
really close homies of mine just trying
to see their friend do some that's true
because Hollywood area is going crazy
Hollywood I'm scared to go out yeah I
look homeless when I go out I'm not some
of the richest people there look
homeless when they go out like Kanye
like yeah when I was saying when we were
walking after that Festival yeah well
how do I say San Marino San Bernardino
reckon my boyfriend he was like because
it was late at night he he was like put
your hood up hide your backpack and walk
like you're cracked out and crazy so we
were just like kind of like walking
really weird we're like no one will
touch us then you know you look like a
local you look like a local so we were
just tweaking
that's the way to do it
[Music]
[Music]